it's been just about six months since
Apple revealed their brand new
redesigned M2 MacBook Air and now that
I've had a lot of time to just sit and
think about this new Macbook and where
the value truly lies I'm convinced that
this is the most refined MacBook design
that has ever come from Apple and to
think that you can now find it on sale
basically everywhere there's literally
never been a better time to buy a base
MacBook model well actually I am wrong I
do think that the next iteration of this
MacBook is gonna be even better for
multiple reasons as I'll get to in just
a minute but that Macbook will pack a
lot of the similar features that we
already have in this one in fact the
design will likely stay exactly the same
so with that said let me get into what
makes this one so special I've been
using my own personal 16-inch M1 Max
MacBook Pro at home for the past year
and I've gotten used to the very heavy
and quite thick design basically
becoming normal to me especially since
the large and excellent display and the
speakers more than make up for it but I
was recently using the M2 MacBook Air at
the office and I was blown away by how
thin the design is with the lid open the
bottom keyboard section is so thin it
doesn't even seem possible for a crazy
powerful computer to sit inside of it
alongside batteries that last a crazy
long time then I just started looking at
the design and really appreciating all
the subtle touches and changes that
Apple made to make it look so clean for
example there's not a single MacBook Air
logo on it with Apple removing it from
the chin section leaving us with a clean
dark strip and they didn't even engrave
it into the bottom like they did for the
14 and 16 inch MacBook Pro there's
literally just an Apple logo on the back
and I love that now you may have not
noticed but Apple also made the trackpad
a bit wider than it was before giving
you more trackpad real estate which is
always good to have I'm also pleasantly
surprised by the quality of the speakers
despite Apple removing the speaker
grills completely for a cleaner look and
just like before they added the notch
which allowed them to thin out the
bezels and make them curve around the
top corners and even though many people
complained about the notch I seriously
do not notice it at all these days it's
just become so normalized that it
doesn't even matter anymore so with that
said the M2 MacBook Air gets my own
personal best MacBook design ever award
and I can't wait to see what Apple does
with it in the future specifically if
Apple actually moves forward with a 15
inch MacBook Air that's been in the
rumor pipeline that would that would
absolutely incredible because it would
fix the limited display size issue that
some people have with this one and it
would make it feel even thinner because
of the wider and larger design sort of
how the 12.9 inch iPad Pro seems
impossibly thin for its size the truth
is that no other laptop or tablet maker
can compete with Apple's combination of
thin design and battery life there's
just no competition now moving on from
that one of my favorite features that
often gets overlooked is the max save 3
connector which I absolutely love using
at home with my current MacBook Pro and
it's even more important on this air
because it only comes with two
Thunderbolt ports so having Max safe is
a game changer previously the old M1
model didn't have this so you always had
to use one of the Thunderbolt ports for
charging leaving you with just one left
for connecting accessories and whatever
else so that makes a port on the new Air
is a game changer for me now the one
area where it's a little bit of a hit or
miss is the performance but before I get
into that I want to show off our sponsor
axter's huge Cyber Monday sale which
includes this 13-inch laptop sleeve made
out of genuine top grain leather with a
discreet magnetic closure and a bunch of
pockets on both sides for all of your
accessories and it also fits the 14 inch
MacBook Pro so check it out using the
links below now getting back to the hit
or miss performance I've been using my
basically fully maxed out 16 inch M1 Max
MacBook Pro for the past year and I've
realized that it's pretty much Overkill
in terms of what I've actually been
doing with it yes I've edited a few
videos and played a few games but to be
completely honest I would have been just
fine with M1 performance but now
thinking about you guys prospective
buyers who could be choosing between an
M2 MacBook Air and a crazy heavy heading
16-inch MacBook Pro I'm actually leaning
more and more towards recommending the
M2 because it simply handles so much for
the price it does just fine with common
video editing music production
programming and much more and the major
benefit is that the M2 Chip excels at
single core tasks which leads to
snappier web browsing performance as
we've seen using the speedometer 2.0 web
browsing Benchmark now of course there
are those of you who actually need a lot
more performance on a regular basis and
to you I say go for the 16 inch or maybe
even the 14 or actually just wait until
March for the new models to come out but
for everyone that's kind of on the fence
and is trying to convince themselves
that they need the most performance
available even though deep down they
know they mostly just browse the web I
would say you should be going for the M2
air especially for this super nice and
thin design but now we're met with a
dilemma and less than one year there
will likely be a brand new M3 MacBook
Air that'll be coming with a host of
benefits and maybe even a 15-inch model
if that's something you'd be interested
in so let's get into what that's going
to look like first off the biggest new
feature is in the name the M3 chip after
following the supply chain it's pretty
clear that this new chip will be based
on tsmc's brand new three nanometer chip
technology which should see a pretty
massive Improvement in efficiency and
performance per watt this essentially
means that the future MacBook Air will
have less thermal throttle issues better
battery life and higher performance as
well now if you didn't already know the
current M2 Chip is basically a stopgap
product based on the same M1 chip as
before but simply tuned up overclocked
and slightly redesigned to include more
memory bandwidth among other things but
as far as the actual efficiency it's
quite a bit worse than the M1 chip in
cinebench R23 the M2 required about 36
percent more power to give us around 11
to 13 percent more performance it also
didn't really give us a performance
boost in terms of playing back more
tracks in logic pro so both of those
things stream
overclocked but the new M3 chip will
come with a brand new three nanometer
design with major improvements across
the board and this might be a big enough
deal by itself to get people to upgrade
but other than that we might even see
some other surprise upgrades like
potentially adding face ID support
Bluetooth 5.3 Wi-Fi 6E and maybe even 5G
cellular service on your MacBook but
besides that we haven't really received
many leaks or rumors concerning the
other features we could be seeing but
honestly I think that this upcoming M3
MacBook Air won't be that much different
and it'll likely stick to internal
changes like the M3 chip and not much
else so if you don't really care that
much about the internal things and you
care more about the design right now is
really the best time to buy this M2
model unless of course you're holding
off for the possibility of a 15-inch
MacBook Air but there are no guarantees
either way I'm really happy with this
laptop and how Apple pulled off the
redesign basically nailing it and giving
the common person the perfect laptop for
a variety of use cases so that just
about sums it all up so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did click
the circle about to subscribe and check
out one of those two videos right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]